ni en espagne alors que la situation
reste tendue dans les hôpitaux les
quatre contamination sont à la baisse de
quoi encourager le gouvernement de
catalogne a levé la quasi totalité des
restrictions sanitaires
en seulement deux semaines la catalogne
est passé d'un couvre-feu a quasiment
aucune restriction le gouvernement
régional a annoncé la levée de la
quasi-totalité des mesures sanitaires
qui était en vigueur depuis la
mi-décembre
ainsi à partir de ce vendredi il n'y
aura plus de limitations pour les
rassemblements sociaux qui était avant
fixé à 10 personnes et puis les jo jeu
d'occupation dans les commerces pour les
salles de spectacle le monde de la
culture la restauration ou encore les
salles de sport élevé et puis le couvre
feu lui avait pris fin la semaine
dernière en bref les seules mesures qui
vont rester en catalogne se rendent tout
d'abord l'obligation du port du masque à
l'extérieur le pas salutaire dans les
restaurants les maisons de retraite et
les salles de sport et puis la fermeture
des discothèques alors ici en catalogne
c'est une décision qui peut surprendre
notamment parce que la tension dans les
hôpitaux est encore élevé le nombre
d'hospitalisations pour coville a
d'ailleurs battu son record de la
sixième vague en début de semaine en
atteignant 2008 116 patients et puis le
taux d'incidence a aussi grimpé ces
derniers jours dans la région avec plus
de 5400 cas de kobe de 19 pour cent
mille habitants en seulement deux
semaines mais le gouvernement catalan
justifie cette levée des restrictions
par un ralentissement de la sixième
vague il mise tout sur le fait que
presque 8 catalan sur dix ont reçu deux
doses de vaccin alors le prochain
dossier sur la table des autorités
catalanes ses petons rouvrir les
discothèques elles sont enfermés depuis
le 23 décembre dernier mais le secteur
demandent une réouverture au 15 février
c'est juste avant la tenue du salon
mondial du mobile à barcelone qui attire
des milliers de professionnels venus du
monde entier